Oh, there we go.
Oh gosh, that's still weird.
It's still weird.
I think I might like this.
Hello!
Lampy!
Thanks for the gift.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Karaoke today!
Oh gosh, I was so...
I was like, oh, you know, what's...
Like, a good way to show off my...
My face.
You know, karaoke I think maybe is a good way.
Is it English or Japanese karaoke?
Whatever!
Whatever I want.
Peanutbutterbutterpuffs, welcome to membership!
Ducky!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
But I...
I was like, what should I do to show off my face?
And I was like, I could do the 3D...
Not 3D, sorry, the karaoke.
But...
I didn't think at all what to sing.
I didn't...
I have no idea.
So...
It's...
It's a mystery.
Raymac, thanks for the 5 gifted!
But thank you guys for being here.
Thank you, thank you.
Nice nude drips.
Thank you!
I'll just sing whatever I want.
I think I have...
I have my switch set up in case I want to do...
Japanese songs.
And of course I have the English.
English songs are probably the easier ones for me to just...
Search up, you know.
You're pretty cute.
I feel like I'm stuck in like this...
I'm stuck in a...
In a trap.
Because...
I don't want you guys to call me cute.
But...
If I say don't call me cute, that's...
It feels like that's insulting...
Ayami mama's art.
So...
You have to say...
What?
It's complicated.
Deluran, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you.
I don't remember if we've ever done any maid cafe songs.
I would love to request Aikome Forever or Dreaming Passport maybe.
Funny thing...
Dreaming Passport...
Dreaming... Dreaming Passport...
Doesn't really...
I don't know if I...
I don't know if there...
I don't think it has an instrumental.
Micmac, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Notorious BSJ, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Ayami's art is cute.
Yeah!
You can say that.
You can say Ayami's art is so cute.
You can say Ayami mama's art...
Oh my god.
Saikou kawaii.
Ayami mama's art.
Even though...
She was...
She was streaming yesterday.
After my debut.
And she was talking about me.
And she was just like...
But if there's no opai...
I must charge more.
Because I'm not...
Because I'm not comfortable withdrawing smaller chests.
Sensei!
Actually, I don't think I've ever shown this before.
But I have something I want to show real quick.
I don't think I've ever shown this before though.
Hold on, give me a second.
I found it earlier.
Because I was just like...
I was like...
This is always how it's been.
I just got...
Everybody got gaslit.
Basically.
Hold on.
One sec.
You're a soup.
Thank you.
Okay, I covered up my ugly handwriting earlier.
Because I was like, I don't want you guys to see that.
And I'm kind of actually really embarrassed to...
You guys can maybe tell me how accurate this is.
So this is what I first sent to KJR Mama.
When I was first telling her how I wanted to look.
So as you can see, this is the Google Doc.
It was from...
I looked, I think it said it was...
It was like...
March.
March or April 2020.
So...
You can see...
Things are kind of...
Oh wait, it's a little cropped one.
Things have not changed so much maybe.
But I'm really embarrassed about my personality.
Why did I write that?
What are you talking about?
I'm a genius.
I'm a genius, what are you talking about?
But I also pointed out things that I was like...
Okay, this has to say...
Or this I want, this I want, this I want.
Look at this.
Do you see this?
Hold on.
Appearance.
It was always...
Always...
Like this!
Always like this!
It was always like this!
And then I had like example haircuts and stuff.
I was like...
And then a hokey.
And then my hitai kakushi.
I don't know why I wrote ghost.
I think I sent this to...
To other artists as well.
Because before I found KJR Mama...
I was looking for other artists and some people were like...
Oh sorry, can't do vtuber model.
So...
I was like...
You know.
I don't know what this means.
Legs can be a little more active.
I don't know what that means.
I don't know, I'm active apparently.
But I really wanted the...
Look, I even have...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, my ushi right here, that's peace-chan.
Active.
So...
Yeah, everybody can shut the hell up.
Being like...
Oh, I think she got smarter.
No.
It was always this way.
From the very start.
From the very beginning.
But I think I'm still...
Average.
Probably.
I don't know.
It doesn't really matter.
What matters is...
My pointy ears.
That's all that matters.
Is my fang smaller?
No, I don't think so.
Actually...
I made it a point because...
Originally, it was just going to be...
Flesh fang.
Because that's kind of Ayami Mama's...
Specialty, I'd say.
But...
I said I wanted both.
Because I've always had the tooth fang.
I made that kind of clear.
I was like, I must have...
I wanted to have, of course...
Ayami Mama's style.
So that's why I kept the flesh fang.
But...
Then I was like, I must have a tooth fang too.
Ayami is number one, mom.
I think so too!
I'm so happy.
How does that work?
It's just my fang, but...
Sticking out.
Kind of.
It's an anime thing, don't...
You humans would not understand.
Flang.
It's a flang.
It's just a flang.
Yeah, so...
You 3D humans...
Don't understand the workings.
I think.
No, you don't get it.
Will we ever see Spaghetti-chan again?
Who?
I don't know anyone by that name.
Spaghetti-chan?
That's weird.
Why is her name Spaghetti?
You guys are being so weird!
What do you mean?
Rest in pasta?
Like my dinner?
Spaghetti?
I had spaghetti the other night.
For food.
Rule 6?
What's rule 6?
Wait, is that the... Wait, I don't remember my own rules.
I don't remember my own rules.
Wiped from the history books.
I do not know.
Anyway.
It's karaoke.
What should I start with?
I don't know.
I don't know what to even start with.
With my Oshi, anything is possible.
Wow, what a dumb pun.
Not sure my mom understands what Vtubers are, but she told me to give you $10 and tell you she says hi.
JB's mom!
Hello!
Thank you!
Why such a hi about?
Your mom is such an enabler.
Could you possibly sing a Detective Conan song?
Zard!
There's only one truth!
A Zard song.
I've sung Zard before.
I would have to remember some of their other ones.
She was a true patriot.
Congrats on 3.0.
Thank you!
Since Shimiko is now technically your sister, any chance for some BA song?
I know, isn't that kind of crazy?
I'm kind of sisters with...
With...
Shimiko.
From Blue Archive.
I did enter a pretty big family, huh?
Any songs stuck in your head lately?
I...
I'm gonna play...
Actually, one thing I've been...
Don't say Monster Mash.
No!
Monster Mash!
That's for Halloween!
It's... It's November 1st!
Oh my gosh, what's some fall songs?
Fall...
What's a fall song?
It's Christmas!
Ne... Wait, wait.
No, hold on, hold on.
Mariah Carey!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
She's alive.
She's always been alive!
She's just defrosted.
She was in a catatonic state.
Frozen tonic state.
I think.
That's how it works.
Maybe.
Alright.
There's one song actually.
Let me see if they have it.
They probably do.
That...
I've been listening.
Honestly, I meant to...
I meant to plug this last night.
Hot dog.
Oh!
Hot dog!
It's all 19 minutes of Alice's Restaurant.
What's that?
Wait, I think I know that actually.
Oh, wait!
I... Wait.
I can't sing it in Spanish though.
I'll try this song.
Wait, this might be way too sad though for the very beginning song.
Maybe.
Oh well.
Actually...
Yeah, I'll just go...
This might be so sad though for the first song.
Sad first is good?
Okay.
I've never sung this one.
It's quite short.
Actually, I don't know...
I don't know the full version.
It's fine.
Let me know how the audio is.
Ah!
Remember me Though I have to say goodbye Remember me Don't let it make you cry For even if I'm far away I hold you in my heart I sing a secret song to you Each night we are apart Remember me Though I have to travel far Remember me Each time you hear a sad guitar Know that I'm with you The only way that I can be
Oh, I forgot to setlist.
One second.
Not spooky setlist anymore.
Just setlist.
Remember me.
Though I have to travel far.
This next song.
Thank you.
Miss Denial.
Denial is not just a river in Egypt.
You as a person are cute.
In addition to Ayami- No!
You cannot say...
Thank you!
Thank you for the hokuto.
Congratulations on a successful re-debut with your new model.
Whisper proud of you, Minto.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna sing the next song, but I might mess it up a little bit.
We're still in warm-up, it's fine.
I'm surprised Ayami-mama didn't give you big honka-badonkas.
She has- You guys, just think of it.
I'm extending her artistic range.
She has to be able to draw all sorts of body types, okay?
I'm extending her- She says I don't draw smaller chests often, so it's just me helping her out as an artist.
It's me helping her out as an artist.
But I also told her if she ever wanted to, she can, so you might see it in the future.
Who knows, she might have some funky doujinshi or something about me.
I gave her full permission.
Yeah.
Just more ectoplasm or something, probably.
Okidoki.
Like I said, I might scuff this.
Who cares?
I don't care!
Oh, kindly requesting the greatest song ever to be sung and featured in Zash- Not the Chi-Chi-Chi-Oppai!
I don't- How does it go again?
I don't even remember.
Sing Doraemon.
Main theme.
I don't know the Doraemon song.
Namtran!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oppai boing boing.
Chi-Chi-Chi-Oppai boing boing.
Ok, I'm singing now, but it's not about Oppai, I'm really sorry.
It's actually kind of a wholesome song, maybe.
It's by Laifei.
Let's see if the sound will be good.
I'm tired when there's no one else around.
Me and you and awkward silence.
Don't you dare look at me that way.
I don't need reminders of how you don't feel the same.
Oh, the burning pain.
Listening to you harp on Balsam Moon.
Soulmate, she's so perfect, blah blah blah blah.
How I wish you'll wake up one day.
Run to me, confess your love, at least just let me say.
That when I talk to you, a cubit walks right through and shoots an arrow through my heart.
And I sound like a fool, but don't you feel it to confess I loved you from the start.
I don't know the ad-libs.
What's a girl to do?
Lying on my bed staring into the blue.
Unrequited, terrifying, love is driving me a bit insane.
Have to get this off my chest, I'm telling you today.
That when I talk to you, a cubit walks right through and shoots an arrow through my heart.
And I sound like a fool, but don't you feel it to confess I loved you from the start.
Confess I loved you, just thinking of you.
I know I'm
the star.
Yeah!
Oh, I forgot to show the setlist, my bad.
That was from the start.
I think it's Lai Fai.
Thanks for the 10 gifts!
Thank you!
Stop!
Why did I do that?
The backing was a bit loud.
I tried adjusting it...
While... I think actually... Hold on, I think I...
Changed it...
Before, that's why.
No, I know the instrumental was loud!
Thank you!
Yeah, I saw someone comment while... And it also sounded loud to me.
When I was singing.
Was it still loud towards the end though?
Should've been okay at the end.
Everybody by Backstreet Boys.
Everybody!
Yeah!
Rock your body!
Caught me off guard and I love your singing.
Thank you!
Will this be archived?
No, it's archived.
It's archived.
It's been a minute since I've done...
Since I've done karaoke, so...
I didn't know I liked that idol group, huh?
I don't... How would I... I don't think...
Hold on, let me check on...
Let me see if they're even on Joy Sound.
Because I like that idol group.
I love that idol group.
Wait, is my switch dead?
I just charged it.
My switch might be dead.
Oh, what?
My switch...
Might be dead.
How does that work?
Because I couldn't super yesterday.
But congrats on 3.0.
Thank you, Tok Tok!
Thank you!
Popular?
Yeah!
Well guys, I guess today is English karaoke only.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I can charge it.
I think it's charging now.
I think so.
I'm popular.
There it is.
I can sing this song.
Hopefully it's not too loud.
If so, I can adjust.
Don't worry.
Let's do it.
Whenever I see someone less fortunate than I And let's face it, who isn't less fortunate than I My tender heart tends to start to bleed And when someone needs a makeover, I simply have to take over I know, I know Exactly What they need And even in your case Though it's the toughest case I've yet to face Don't worry I'm determined to succeed Follow my lead And yes,
indeed You will be Popular You're gonna be popular I'll teach you the proper poise When you talk to boys Little ways to flirt and flounce I'll show you what shoes to wear How to fix your hair Everything that really counts to be popular I'll help you be popular You'll hang with the right cohorts You'll be good at sports Know the slang you've got to know So let's start Cause you've got an awfully long way to go Don't be offended by my frank analysis.
Think of it as personality dialysis.
Now that I've chosen to become a pal, a sister, an advisor.
There's nobody wiser, not when it comes to popular.
I know about popular.
And with an assist from me, to be who you'll be.
Instead of dreary, who you were, well are.
There's nothing that can stop you from becoming popular.
Lar, lar.
La, la, la, la.
We're gonna make you popular.
When I see depressing creatures.
I don't know the tune in this part, depressing creatures.
I remind them on their own behalf.
To think of celebrated heads of state.
Or especially great communicators.
Did they have brains or knowledge?
Don't make me laugh.
They were popular.
Please.
It's all about popular.
It's not about aptitude.
It's the way you're viewed.
So it's very shrewd to be.
Very, very popular.
Like me.
Why, chat.
Look at you.
You're beautiful.
I have to go.
You're welcome.
Though you protest.
Your disinterest.
I know clandestinely.
You're gonna grin and bear it.
Your newfound popularity.
Lar, lar, la, la.
You'll be popular.
Just not quite as popular as me.
Oh guys, don't you know I'm the most...
That song is all about me.
You know me.
I'm the most popular gal there is.
I'm...
I'm not...
I'm so popular.
Incredible job channeling her.
Thank you, Kristin Chenoweth.
Stop it.
Oh my god, this is so weird.
I love Kristin Chenoweth.
Dead girl walking from Heather's...
What is that?
The one where he goes...
You better come out now, Heather.
I'm counting to three.
One, two...
Fuck it.
Sure, grandma.
I don't know that.
No, that's meant to be yours.
Oh shoot.
I don't know what that...
I know kind of like...
I'm a dead girl walking.
I think.
I don't know.
Bye, Zack.
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
I don't know if I'm ever saying your name right.
I'm so sorry.
Dead girl singing.
Suddenly Seymour, please.
Why is it suddenly turning into all musicals?
Christmas song.
What is a Christmas song?
It's a Christmas song.
Christmas song.
Jingle bells.
All I want for Christmas.
Leila, thanks for the five gifted.
Last Christmas.
Thanks for three votes.
Snow Halation.
Yeah, but I don't have the...
My switch right now is dead.
It's charging, I think.
Let me double check.
I think it's charging.
Wait, it might be on.
Wait, I just remembered.
I think it's on.
Wait.
It's on.
Oh my gosh, you guys, I couldn't see.
I'm stupid because it's plugged in.
I've been trying to power it off this whole time.
You guys, see, hold on.
Wait.
See?
It was on this whole time.
So we do have Japanese songs.
I just have to...
Hello?
My Joy-Cons aren't connecting.
Sonic.
Hello?
Joy-Cons?
Well, while I get this set up, let's sing something else too.
Boomerang.
Thank you for the 20 yen.
Thank you.
Snow Halation.
Here, I'll sing...
A Christmas song.
I guess it's the season, huh?
Father Christmas by the Kings.
I don't know if I know that one.
Christmas, Christmas.
Oh, this one's the Carpenters.
Christmas song.
What is this one?
I'm like, I'm just going to pick a song I don't even know.
Why isn't it working?
My Joy-Cons.
Wait.
Christmas song.
Oh!
Chestnuts Roasting on an Open Fire.
All through the year we...
I don't know this song.
I give up.
It says Chestnuts Roasting on an Open Fire.
That's completely a lie.
Wait.
Christmas song, start now.
Cursed Mariah.
That was the intro.
I'll let her sing it then.
Bring in the wintertime, bring in the happiest season of all.
Chestnuts roasting on an open fire.
Jack Frost nipping at your nose.
Yuletide carols being sung by a choir.
And folks dressed up like Eskimos.
Everybody knows a turkey and some mistletoe help to make the season bright.
Tiny tots.
Tater tots.
A little pause.
Hard to sleep tonight.
They know that Santa's on his way.
He's loaded lots of tater tots.
Sorry.
I said toys but I thought I said tots again.
The reindeer really know how to fly.
And so I'm offering this simple praise to kids from 1 to 92.
Am I hungry or something?
Although it's been said many times.
There's many ways.
Merry Christmas to you.
They know that Santa's on his way.
He's on his way.
He's loaded lots of tater tots.
For his sleigh.
And every mother's child.
Why did I go up in an octave?
To see if a reindeer really know how to fly.
And so...
I'm sorry I can't get over it.
I'm sorry.
Although it's been said many times.
There's many ways.
Merry Christmas to you.
I'm not putting this on the set list.
In fact, I'm not doing another Christmas song.
No more Christmas songs.
Oh my gosh, I can't stop thinking about tater tots.
I was actually tearing up.
Oh my goodness, Goofy.
OK,
let me try to get my Switch to...Oh, it turned off.
I'm a Goofy Goober.
Oh, start.
Why are my Joy-Cons not working?
Start, please.
Your re-debut yesterday...
Filled my dark soul with light.
Maybe...
Oh, that's why.
I'm an idiot, guys.
I'm really sorry.
Once again, I...
Update the system.
Oh, update software.
Oh wait, no, system update.
OK, guys, let's sing another English song.
Because I have to update my...
I have to update my Switch.
You'll be back from Hamilton.
I'm sorry, I don't know any Hamilton songs.
I haven't watched it.
I only know Alexander Hamilton.
I've listened to the demos of Hamilton more than I've listened to the actual songs.
I'm so sorry.
Alexander Hamilton, Alexander Hamilton.
That's all I know.
Fly me to the moon.
Someone asked for that earlier, so...
I can do that one.
But which one is it always?
I never know.
There's like 50... Oh my gosh.
There's actually so many versions of this song.
Oh, OK, never mind.
I put in fly me to the moon and it gave me 27,000 results actually.
Invisible Moose, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Dancing Queen by Ava.
I can do that one too.
I'll do it after.
Maybe this one is...
Good.
It's the uptempo one, but is it too uptempo?
I don't know.
Fly me to the moon and let me play among the stars.
Let me see what spring is like on Jupiter and Mars.
In other words, hold my hand.
It's right here.
In other words, darling, kiss me.
Fill my heart with song and let me sing forevermore.
You are all I long for, all I worship and adore.
In other words, please be true.
In other words...
I wonder if you can do a mix here.
It's kind of slow though.
Fill my heart with song and let me sing forevermore.
You are all I long for, all I worship and adore.
In other words, please be true.
In other words...
You can quit though.
She hates us.
Nonsense.
Whatever, whatever, whatever.
Skip the gap version.
You can dance.
You can jump.
We'll see that girl.
Watch that scene.
Dig in the dancing queen.
I love this song.
Friday night and the lights are low.
Looking out for a place to go.
Where they play the right music.
Getting in the swing.
You gotta look for a king.
Anybody could be that guy.
The night is young and the music's high.
With a bit of rock music, everything is fine.
You're in the mood for a dance.
And when you get the chance.
You are the dancing queen.
Young and sweet, forever nineteen.
Dancing queen.
Feel the beat from the tambourine.
Oh yeah.
You can dance.
You can jive.
Having the time of your life.
We'll see that girl.
Watch that scene.
Dig in the dancing queen.
You're a teaser.
You turn him on.
And you get the chance.
You are the dancing queen.
Young and sweet, forever nineteen.
Dancing queen.
Feel the beat from the tambourine.
Oh yeah.
You can dance.
You can jive.
We'll see that girl.
Watch that scene.
Dig in the dancing queen.
Dancing queen.
Oh my gosh.
I've been seeing so many of those...
Like those 3D ABBA concerts.
I wanna go so bad.
Goodbye to Love by the Carpenters.
I don't know if I know it.
How many times have you been stuck in a Ghostbusters trap with slime?
Never.
Ghostbusters?
Wish they could catch me.
V3 Minto, you're my favorite.
V1 looked like she was about to cry.
What do you mean by that?
V2 hated us.
Yeah, only V2.
Consider I will survive or diamonds are forever.
Diamonds are forever.
Thank you.
I don't know that one.
I don't think.
Diamonds are forever.
Do I know that one?
What was the other one?
Oh, I will survive.
I will survive.
That one?
Oh gosh.
I could try it.
I don't know if I've ever...
For Japanese songs, I have to use like a timed...
Oh, I have enough yen, right?
Oh gosh, I didn't really think about it.
I'm so unprepared for today.
I'm really sorry.
I will survive.
Let's see.
Everyone at my Halloween party is cheering you...
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean?
Like a lot of people are watching?
Joy, thank you.
But no, it's a matter of like...
I would have to buy a new yen card.
A new like, you know...
Oh my gosh, eShop card.
So maybe today will just be English.
We'll see.
I don't know if I can sing this song well.
I just walked in to find you here With that sad look upon your face Should have changed that stupid lock I should have made you leave your key If I had known for just one second You'd be back to bother me So go on, go!
Walk out the door Just turn around now Cause you're not welcome anymore Weren't you the one who tried to hurt me with goodbye?
Did you think I'd crumble?
Did you think I'd lay down and die?
Oh no, not I!
I will survive Oh, as long as I don't...
Oh no, I have the performance anxiety!
I'll survive I will survive
Took all the strength I had Not to fall apart Wait, how does this part go?
This is all my broken heart And I spent oh so many nights Just feeling sorry for myself I used to cry But now I hold my head up high And you see me Somebody new I'm not that chained up little person Still in love with you And so you felt like dropping in And just expect me to be free Well now I'm saving all my loving For someone who's loving me Go on now,
Kyle.
Walk out the door.
Just turn around now, cause you're not welcome anymore.
Weren't you the one who tried to break me with goodbye?
Did you think I'd crumble?
Did you think I'd lay down and die?
Oh no, not I.
I will survive.
Oh, as long as I know how to love, I know I'll stay alive.
I've got all my life to live, and I've got all my love to give.
And I'll survive.
I will survive.
Oh...
Go on now, Kyle.
Walk out the door.
Just turn around now, cause you're not welcome here anymore.
Weren't you the one who tried to break me with goodbye?
Did you think I'd crumble?
Did you think I'd lay down and die?
Oh no, not I.
I will survive.
Oh, as long as I know how to love, I know I'll stay alive.
I've got all my life to live, and I've got all my love to give.
And I'll survive.
I will survive.
Oh, as long as I know how to love, I know I'll stay alive.
Got all my life to live, and I've got all my love to give.
And I'll survive.
I will survive.
It's really awkward as a ghost singing that song.
I don't have all my life to live.
Um, but you know, it's just a song.
It's just a song.
I will survive.
I want to try and sing.
Can I get a, okay, hold on.
I know I'm like mid karaoke, but can I practice real quick?
Hold on.
I, cause I want to have a revengeance of the song I sang with Urb yesterday.
Thank you, Minty, for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
I love your voice.
Thank you.
Um, what was it called?
Revengeance?
Yeah, my revengeance.
Um, oh, die with a smile.
Maybe I should do Bruno Mars' part.
No, I really just wanted like, I wanted like, Elizabeth to just sing so much of the song.
So I gave her, I was like Bruno Mars to you.
Hold on though.
This is a practice real quick.
I have to hear the harmonies.
I think I remember it, but it's also, I get kind of my brain.
Okay.
We're just going to have to listen to not Bruno Mars for a minute though.
Cause he sings the beginning.
So, okay.
This is the die with a smile.
I wish it was Elizabeth, but I forgot to ask her if I could use her, her version again.
So I'm so sorry.
You're stuck with not Bruno Mars.
Instead of Liz's beautiful, beautiful, beautiful, beautiful, beautiful, beautiful, amazing voice.
Can you believe her?
She's so amazing.
She said it was an honor to sing with me.
I was like, girl, no.
What are you talking about?
So I'm gonna love you every night, like it's the last night, like it's the last night.
If the world was empty, I want to be next to you.
If the party was over, and our time on earth was through, I'd wanna hold you just for a while.
And die with a smile.
If the world was empty, I'd wanna be next to you.
Oh, oh.
Oh, we're lost.
Lost in the words that we scream.
I don't even wanna do this anymore.
Cause you already know what you mean to me.
And our love's the only war worth fighting for.
Wherever you go, that's where I'll follow.
Nobody's promised tomorrow.
So I'ma love you every night, like it's the last night, like it's the last night.
If the world was empty, I'd wanna be next to you.
If the party was over, and our time on earth was through, I'd wanna hold you just for a while.
And die with a smile.
If the world was empty, I'd wanna be next to you.
Right next to you.
Get away from me, not Bruno Mars.
Next to you.
Right next to you.
If the world was ending, I'd wanna be next to you.
If the party was over, and our time on earth was through, I'd wanna hold you just for a while.
And die with a smile.
If the world was ending, I'd wanna be next to you.
I'd wanna be next to you.
Hey,
I kinda remembered it.
I was so struck yesterday though, gosh, what a queen.
Maybe one day I can use her version again.
But it'll be awkward because she'll be like, congrats on your 3.0, and I'll be like, that was like 5 months ago, but thanks.
Sad not with herb though.
With fake Bruno Mars.
Someone asked about something earlier and I can't remember what it was.
Hot dog.
You're not just a dancing queen, you're a singing queen.
Oh goodness gracious, great balls of fire.
No, no.
I have a... Hot to go?
Wait, I sang it yesterday, is it okay?
I don't think I'm really good at singing that song though.
I don't know.
I don't think I'm really good at singing it though.
It was Narissa's choice.
I was really happy though that I was able to...
Because I chose Narissa and Liz, and they do mostly English songs, so I was just like, oh, if I sing... At first I was like, should we do Japanese songs, but they said it would be okay since on my channel I can keep it up.
The first time I heard that song was yesterday, thank you and herb did it best.
Love me, love me, love me.
What's that one?
Okay, hot to go.
Hot to go but just me.
Sad, lonely.
Oh my goodness.
5, 6, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Oh, the aishite.
I could
be the one or your new addiction.
It's all in my head, but I want nonfiction.
I don't want the world, but I'll take this city.
Who can blame a girl?
Call me hot, not pretty.
Baby, do you like this beat?
I made it so you dance with me.
It's like 199 degrees.
When you're doing it with me, doing it with me.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
Snap and clap and touch your toes.
Raise your hands now, body roll.
Dance it out, you're hot to go.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
Snap and clap and touch your toes.
Raise your hands now, body roll.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
You can take me hot to go.
Well, I woke up alone staring at my ceiling.
I try not to care, but it hurts my feelings.
You don't have to stare.
Come here, get with it.
No one's touched me there in a damn minute.
And baby, don't you like this beat?
I made it so you'd sleep with me.
It's like 199 degrees.
When you're doing it with me, doing it with me.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
Snap and clap and touch your toes.
Raise your hands now, body roll.
Dance it out, you're hot to go.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
Snap and clap and touch your toes.
Raise your hands now, body roll.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
You can take me hot to go.
What's it take to get your number?
What's it take to bring you home?
Hurry up, it's time for supper.
Order up, I'm hot to go.
What's it take to get your number?
Hurry up, it's getting cold.
Hurry up, it's time for supper.
Order up, I'm hot to go.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
You can take me hot to go.
It's hot in here.
Is anyone else hot?
You're coming home with me, right?
Okay, it's hot.
Hold on, I need a sippy.
Oh my gosh, do you guys want to see how I look when I eat?
Here, I'll grab a chip.
I'll grab a chip.
Where's a chip?
My stash of chips.
These ones are in the shapes of ghosts.
Looks just like a guy going like...
Okay.
They're veggie chips, so they're good for me probably.
Yummy.
Okay, I'm done.
Okay.
Sorry if you hate ASMR chewing.
Maybe I should've done a warning.
I get the Moe aesthetic now.
Moe is justice.
I feel we are losing Moe way.
But Moe is everything.
Moe should be in all of our lives and afterlives, I believe.
I'm a Moe connoisseur.
Moe cute is life and afterlife.
Basically.
Hi.
Hi!
Thanks for the superchat!
Someone actually brought up the carpenters earlier.
It makes me want to sing a carpenter song.
I hope it's okay.
It's a song I think about.
Every time I think about Snake, I think about this song.
Wait, where is it?
Wait, one second.
Your new model is so cute.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
One second.
What can I find here?
Did I put it in wrong?
No?
It was here.
Let me put it like this.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I always think of Snake with this song.
You are near, just like me.
They long to be close to you.
Why do stars fall down from the sky every time you walk by?
You are near, just like me.
They long to be close to you.
On the day that you were born, the angels got together and decided to create a dream come true.
So they sprinkled moon dust in your hair and golden starlight in your eyes of blue.
That is why all the girls in town follow you all around.
You are near, just like me.
They long to be close to you.
I am looking at him right now.
Oh, my little Snake.
I love you so much.
You are the cutest little guy ever.
I love you.
I love you so much.
On the day that you were born, the angels got together and decided to create a dream come true.
So they sprinkled moon dust in your hair and golden starlight in your eyes of blue.
That is why all the girls in town follow you all around.
You are near, just like me.
They long to be close to you.
I
bought like three more recently.
Love,
close to you.
Ah, close to you.
Ah,
close to you.
Should I get closer?
Yeah,
I have... How many do I have now of these little Snake Power Pro guys?
Maybe like seven?
Seven, I think.
I can't stop ordering them.
I'm gonna have an army forever.
Am I too close?
I'm gonna lick you if I get any closer.
Don't worry, I'm not gonna lick you.
In my head I'm imagining a music video and it was from mostly the point of view of Ocelot.
Yes, exactly!
Exactly, you get it, you get it, you get it.
I think I might be Ocelot.
Maybe.
Oh gosh.
I think I would destroy the world for Snake.
I'm blushing out, Minto.
There was something else that I thought of singing.
I can't remember what it was, I should have written it down.
Are you okay?
Are you okay, Ducky?
Mint would totally misinterpret Snake's will.
No.
No!
I don't know what that guy wants.
Gosh, what was I gonna sing?
Very cute!
Oh my gosh, you guys, look when I...
Hold on.
Watch my lips.
Sometimes it does it, sometimes it doesn't.
But let's see if it does it today.
Oh, you can kind of see.
It kind of works.
Oh, that was close to you.
One second.
Close.
Oh my gosh, the song that I was wanting to sing is on the tip of my tongue, but I can't remember.
I can't remember.
Oh, it's gonna annoy me.
Can't remember.
There was something that I was like...
I was like, oh, okay, I'm gonna sing this.
But I think I will sing this song that I saw in the chat.
But I have to get a karaoke for it.
And I have to get dressed.
I have to get dressed.
Do you guys like my eyepatch?
Did you guys see the picture that Ayami Mama posted on Twitter?
So actually, that's how the eyepatch came to be.
Because she drew...
Actually, she drew...
She drew a lot of really funny faces.
Before we came up with the cat eye one...
I had drawn something similar to the cat eye, but it looked off.
It looked weird.
So we were like, let's brainstorm some stuff.
And she drew me as a Pepe.
And she drew me as a South Park character.
And she drew me as a...
What were the other ones?
But then she also drew that...
Snake version, and I was like...
Show?
I'll show!
I'll ask her if I can...
I'll ask her if I can show...
Hold on, let me see if...
Where is she?
I don't think she's awake yet.
Gosh, I'm sleepy.
Oh my goodness.
It was a long time ago though, so I have to go way back.
Oh gosh.
Oh, there's me naked.
Oh, I found it!
Oh, the other one was just like...
Funky, like...
Round eyes.
Wow!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Punished Venominto.
Hold on.
But yeah, then she also drew...
The snake, and I was like...
It actually...
She had like the big mint on it, and I kind of...
I didn't tell her to keep it...
But I kind of wish she had kept it.
Let me see.
Okay.
Alright, okay.
I'm gonna sing another song.
Oh, this one.
Yeah.
I love my eyepatch.
There was a reason I wasn't going to go with an eyepatch for this.
But...
Um...
Because I actually had another outfit planned with an eyepatch.
But I...
Then saw it, and I was like, you know what?
Whatever.
Everything can have an eyepatch.
Oh my gosh, I need to message her even and be like...
Hey, when are we starting the next outfit?
Michael, thanks for the gifted!
I need my phantom cigar.
Okey-dokey.
Is this?
Hold on.
Let me check this one real quick.
Oh wait, I'm stupid.
I have my own karaoke.
I got it from the actual...
I was looking it up on YouTube.
I have my own that I got from the official soundtrack.
I think I own all Metal Gear CDs now, you guys.
Yippee!
If there's a song I want, I have it.
Oh, this might be it.
Wait.
Let me turn it up, because it actually might be quiet.
Oh wait, I need lyrics.
But now, love can kill, love will die, give me wings to fly.
Feeling this world so cold, I just wonder why.
Cold as the dark, now my words are frosted with every breath.
Still the hate burns wild, growing inside this heart.
When the wind changes course, when the stars align.
I will reach out to you and leave this all behind.
When heaven's divine.
Now I have an iPod 4.
I actually really wanted an iPod 4.
Metal Gear Solid 3, I almost delayed playing it so I could have it.
Now I have it for the rest of the games though.
When heaven's divine, I will see the choices within my hands.
How can we ever protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fear.
Do you feel the storm approach as the end draws near?
When heaven's divine, time will come to softly lay me down.
Then I can see a face that I long to see.
And for you, only you, I would give anything.
Leaving a trace for love to find a way.
When heaven's divine.
I will dive into the fire, spilling the blood of my desire.
The very last time, my name scorched into the sky.
When heaven's divine, I will see the choices within my hands.
How can we ever protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fear.
Do you feel the storm approach as the end draws near?
When heaven's divine, time will come to softly lay me down.
Then I can see a face that I long to see.
And for you, only you, I would give anything.
Leaving a trace for love to find a way.
When heaven's divine.
Yay!
I'm so glad I can sing that song.
Without any permission stuff.
Yay!
That was Heaven's Divide from Metal Gear Solid.
Peace Obaka!
One of my favorite Metal Gear games.
So underrated.
So, so, so, so underrated.
Vic Boss!
Yeah!
Actually there's another song I wanna sing.
I hope it's okay.
This one I've never sung before.
But I've been listening to it a lot more recently.
Oh, let me...
I've been listening to it a lot more recently and...
It's kind of maybe sad, but...
ZZ!
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you!
Tempest!
Thank you for the 10 gift!
Thank you so much!
Hold on.
Oh, here.
I'm gonna sing a piano version of this song.
I think...
Hold on.
Pretty sure it's this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
This one...
Like I said, I've been listening to it a lot more...
Minty!
Thank you for another 10!
Thank you, thank you!
Really appreciate it!
Thank you, thank you, thank you so much, you guys!
Then maybe after this we can go to some JP songs.
How's that sound?
Hope it's way too far.
I can do that one after.
But this one's not Metal Gear.
Is the switch ready?
Yeah, it's all good.
Wichita Lineman?
Okay, stop.
You guys are picking all my favorites.
How do you guys know that song?
I heard that once on NPR, I think it was.
Wow!
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you!
Lonely Star?
Lonely Rolling Star.
Wait, okay, way too far.
Hold on, I'm making a list.
Okay, I can sing these.
You get better every time you sing, boss?
I really wanted to do singing lessons.
Because I want to get better at making my voice sound more powerful for some songs.
I think.
Okay.
Alright, this song.
I have the lyrics.
Okay.
This point reminds me of eons gone by An astro girl watching galaxies rise and fall Wondering the meaning of it all Till like a comet you came into my orbit I know I'm not alone
I'm not alone
So, now you are here.
The constellations are so clear.
Your gravity is pulling me, until our hearts collide.
My satellite, their darkness is my light.
The darkest night's got the cosmos at our feet, but you are all I need.
Though we've just begun, I know we'll make it.
Cause somehow, the universe is fun now.
Sunrise and night can be so intertwined.
The event horizon line between darkness and light.
An astro girl watching her story come and go.
Pondering the punchline of the joke.
Till like a comet, you came into my orbit, I know.
When our hearts grow bigger than the sun, there's no challenge we can't overcome.
So send them over and watch our supernova explode.
I'm not alone, now you are here.
The constellations are so clear.
Infinity sounds good to me, as long as you are by my side.
The Milky Way's not far away when our love travels faster than the speed of light.
Let's go, I know, we'll make it.
Cause somehow, the universe is fun.
That was
Astro Girl.
Love that song.
Oh, grill.
Astro Girl.
Such a cute song.
This version is so beautiful and then the original is so cute.
Astro Grill.
Means a lot to hear Astro Girl.
I hope I did it okay.
I hope I did it justice.
Let's see.
Let's see, way too foul.
Oh no, it's not on carophone.
Hold on, am I gonna get really copyright struck, I wonder.
I wonder.
Also, there was a raid.
I didn't catch who it was, I was singing.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Thank you for singing Astro Girl.
Of course, thank you.
For letting me sing it.
Way too foul.
Karaoke.
Let me see if any of these work.
I guess this works.
It's a little crunchy sounding, but it should be okay.
Lucky ducky, I do my best.
I've never sung this before.
Hopefully it's okay.
Oh wait, I have to have my patch on again.
They'll tell you what they know But they won't show
I've got something in my throat I need to be alone
Oh son, oh I'm sorry, the lyrics are kind of off.
You'd better wait to shine.
They'll tell you what is yours, but they'll take a bite.
Oh,
I've got something in my throat.
I need to be alone while I suffer.
Oh,
there's a hole inside my boat.
I need to stay afloat for the summer long.
Oh, I've got something in my throat.
I need to be alone while I suffer.
Oh,
there's a hole inside my boat.
I need to stay afloat for the summer.
Son, you'd better wait to fall.
They'll tell you where to go, but they won't.
070707 for the boss.
Ok, I'm over it.
Okie doke, that was wait to fall.
How long have I been?
Oh, only two hours.
Ok, not even.
Ok, cool.
How are we feeling about how I look, you guys?
Are we ok?
It's not too much of a difference, I feel, than before.
I think I look mostly the same, so maybe it's not as dramatic, I suppose.
Maybe it's not as dramatic, probably.
Maybe I think I'm more used to it than you guys, though.
Because I have been staring at it for like a month.
Sarah, how's your Cyberpunk?
Dad, why do you always recommend songs?
I do not know, I feel terrible.
You always, always ask for songs, and I'm like, I'm sorry, I don't know.
Yours and my music tastes do not overlap at all.
Ok, next one.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe you guys like wanting me to sing this song.
It's like the most old person song ever.
I think I don't have to change the key, but I might have to sing it high up, though.
Old people song.
I'm looking for the county.
And I drive the main road.
Searching in the sun for another overload.
I hear you singing in the wire.
I can hear you through the wire.
And the witch's alignment is still on the line.
I know I need a small vacation.
But it don't look like rain.
And if it snows, that stretch down south won't ever stand the strain.
And I need you more than want you.
And I want you for all time.
And the witch's alignment is still on the line.
It's like one of my favorite lyrics actually ever written.
At one bar.
It's so pretty.
It makes my heart cute.
I think I say it again here.
Yeah!
And I need you more than want you.
And I want you for all time.
And the witch's alignment is still on the line.
That was the witch's alignment.
Oh my gosh.
Such a good song.
It's so good.
Like I said, that one, that lyric part is like some of my favorite lyrics of all time.
I don't know, it just feels so poetic.
It makes me feel things.
It makes me feel like, oh my gosh, this is... cute.
Cute!
I really want to stay at your house.
What do you mean by that, Tuna?
Tuna.
Tuna!
What do you mean by that?
Invisible by Duran Duran.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the haka!
Haka, thank you.
I remember listening to this.
And then not learning it.
Oh, invisible.
Invisible.
Hold on, let me listen to it real quick.
Let me see if I remember any of it.
Hold on.
I'm listening.
Sorry if my song recommendation wasn't good.
What are you talking about, Nan?
It's not that it's not good.
I just don't know.
I'm sure your songs are awesome.
Sorry, it's me.
It's not you.
I think I remember just the chorus.
I want to hear her sing that too.
What are you talking about?
Tuna's request is a song from Cyberpunk.
Yeah, I only remember the chorus.
What?
A golden hour and it's original key?
I can't do original key.
Are you crazy?
Like, what?
Okay,
I promise.
We'll do a Metal Gear themed karaoke and when I do, this will be on there, okay?
Pinky promise.
Break your promise, break your pinky, okay?
I promise, promise, okay?
Break your promise, break your pinky.
Let me see if this is actually...
Okay.
This should be good.
Wait, this part.
It's been like, probably 10 years since I've listened to this song.
Contains
I don't remember this part.
Sorry, I completely forgot the middle of that song.
Whoopsie, whoopsie daisy.
Like I said, it's been a long time since I've listened to it.
Okay, let's hope that I have enough yen for JP songs.
Otherwise, I can do...
That will be on...
YouTube.
Do you know Katamari Mambo or Roll Me In?
I don't think so.
I'm sorry.
Don't dream it's over.
I can do that one.
Later.
I don't know, can you guys hear the joy sound?
Wait, hold on.
Can you hear it?
Yeah, it's not echoed, right?
Yeah, okay, now we're good.
Oh, they're doing a free period.
Let's see what songs are free.
Okay, let's go.
It's only like certain...
Sorry, certain songs.
Let's see...
Oh wait, would it help if you guys saw too?
It's gonna be in front of me though.
Put it like right down there.
I can scoot over.
I'm getting away from you stinkies.
Yes.
Oh,
is that it?
This is all of them?
That's it?
Like I know some of these, but I don't know how to sing them.
Okay, nevermind.
I have to spend money.
Liz!
Is that actually you?
Is that actually her?
I was gushing about you earlier.
I thought she would have like a little checkmark though, right?
Wouldn't she have a checkmark?
Hold on, I'm gonna go to her channel.
She didn't yesterday.
Oh, really?
Wait, she was in my chat yesterday too?
Oh, she doesn't have a checkmark.
Liz!
Oh my goodness.
It's an honor to see you.
You didn't know?
I didn't see her.
Oh, I feel so bad.
I was so nervous.
I wasn't really looking so much at chat sometimes.
I was nervous.
She called you princess.
She's like the sweetest ever.
She keeps calling me sweetheart.
And she says it on stream too, and every time I'm like...
Glad to be a Minto member on my birthday.
Muhal and happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Muhal and happy birthday to you.
I was having a great time with your peeps and chat before Halloween.
I hope they weren't too freaky to you.
Oh my gosh.
I haven't been... I haven't stopped repeating your Blackbird cover.
It's so beautiful.
If you guys haven't listened to it, please.
It's so good.
They were awesome?
Good.
I can't stop the loneliness.
Who's that by?
Mekanoid Prime.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Thanks for taking the time to listen.
Of course.
So beautiful.
That's so, so nice.
Oh, you're messaging me.
Oh, it's me.
Thank you for confirming.
What was I... Oh, JP songs.
I don't know what to sing now.
Ask... Oh, I'm nervous though.
Liz, if you're still here, if you're still here, stay with me.
Oh, I can do that one.
Well, I was only going to do it today, but I already did do it.
Would it be okay... I guess I'll do an encore later if she's okay with it.
I am.
Would you be okay if I did your...
Okay, good.
Good one.
Would you be okay if I use your version of the karaoke again?
More than okay?
Okay, guys.
Today will be the last... Today will be the last time that I use it.
Since she's okay with it.
Hopefully though we can, I don't know, sing again together in the future.
I don't know.
What if I just search stay with me.
Okay, hold on.
Let me write down some of these so I don't forget.
Love EXE.
Always good to do haoko.
She said you can use it whenever.
But...
But it was a special thing, you guys.
I can't use it all the time.
It won't become so special anymore.
It was a special thing.
But thank you.
Thank you, ARB!
Okay.
Utaimasu.
Nihongo.
The e-shop.
Hold on.
I forgot that I have to pay.
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
Hopefully I have the money.
Hopefully I have enough yen.
90 days.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Let's do 3 hours.
How much yen do I have?
I don't have enough money.
I have to get another...
I have to get another card.
I have 220 yen.
No, no, no, no, no.
You guys, it's not a matter of like...
It's not a matter of sending money.
It's a matter of me having to...
Usually I like ask a friend in Japan to get me an e-shop card.
But I didn't think about it.
It's okay.
I can still sing this song.
But maybe my options are also a little bit more limited.
Because I can't sing like official versions or I will get the karaoke taken down.
No!
Oh, man.
I'm so sorry, guys.
That's my fault for not checking before stream.
That's my fault.
VTuber no money.
To you.
Yes, my love, to you.
That was Aria.
Here we go.
Stay with me
Oh my gosh, I couldn't breathe for a second.
Stay with me.
I knocked on the midnight door.
I cried out, don't go home.
That season is right in front of me.
Stay with me.
Welcome back, master and mistress.
I think it was Kuro.
Thank you.
I think I remember the name, right?
Hello everybody, I'm Mint Fighter.
I'm a ghost made vtuber.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
That was... Oh!
I haven't been updating the list.
After Lonely Rolling Star, what did I do?
What did I sing?
Nothing?
Oh, really?
I could die happy now thinking of my dovecore?
C2!
CC!
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Oh, okay.
There's a song I want to sing.
I don't know if I'll be able to.
I might forget some in the middle.
Is that okay?
Is it okay if I forget some in the middle?
Oh yeah, because I was trying to figure things out.
Actually, I heard this song first from Kiwawa.
So hopefully I can sing it well.
In fact, maybe I'll sing it with the key melody in the background.
It's so long!
I don't know if I'll be able to.
Actually, I heard this song first from Kiwawa.
I can't read!
Sorry.
I can't read even though I just sang stay with me.
Now, I'm not.
Sorry.
I can't read even though I just sang stay with me.
Now, I'm not.
Sorry.
I can't read even though I just sang stay with me.
Now, I'm not.
That was...
Pretender question mark.
Sorry for the scoff.
Beautiful Mito, thank you!
Thank you!
There was scoff?
Yes!
Yes, there was scoff.
Mod Erb, please.
Mod people that are mods of my chat.
So, I'm sorry.
I love Erb, but... Sorry.
Could an eShop card be sent through Super Chat?
Would it have to be a JP card?
I guess technically the code could be sent through Super Chat, but that wouldn't stop people from using the code.
Other than me!
Thank you!
Yeah, YouTube doesn't have a VIP sort of thing like Twitch does.
But it's okay.
I see her around.
I see her, no worries.
It would have to be in JP for the other thing.
Let me see.
I wonder if they have this as a karaoke.
Oh, this is Utatte Mita, so maybe not.
Hold on.
Let me see if this one... This is a mad, but I think it's not a karaoke.
No.
Unfortunately, I can't do Love EXE.
There's no karaoke.
Wait, let me see if this person can hear them.
Yeah, I can.
Otherwise, I would love to do Love EXE.
I want to do this one though.
Hold on real quick.
Let me see.
It's not summer, but whatever.
Odori Iko!
Oh, I can do that one too.
Love EXE is amazing.
Next time when I have Japanese, like full joy sound, I will do.
So sorry, so sorry.
One second.
Let me check if this one...
I'm trying to find a good...
I don't want the guide melody for this song.
Hold on.
Yen Card.
Oh, it's not real.
I was like, oh guys, I'm not ready.
I have to prepare.
Someone else is going to steal it.
You got me, Dokutalk.
Sam, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Here we go.
Ima zetsubou no fuchi ni tatte Fumikiri e to tobidashita Sou, kimi wa tomodachi Boku no te wo tsukameyo Sou, kimi wa hitori sa Ibasho nante nai darou Futari kimi kono mama Aishiaeru sa Kurikaesu flashback Semi no koe Nidoto wa kaeranu kimi Towa ni chigireteku Osoromi no keyholder Natsu ga keshisatta Shiroi hada no shoujo ni Katashii hodo Toritsukarete shimaitai
Aozora Kimi wa tomodachi
Sou, kimi wa tomodachi Boku no te wo tsukameyo Sou, kimi ga inakucha Ibasho nante nainai yo Tsukitotta sekai de Aishiaetara
Kurikaesu Flashback, semi no koe Nidoto wa kaeranu kimi Tou ni chigireteku Osoromi no key holder Natsu ga keshisaito Shiroi hada no shoujo ni Kanashii hodo Toritsukarete shimaitai Toumei na kimi wa boku wo yubi Sashiteta
Thank you so much for the 10 gifts!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Odoriko I have it somewhere.
Somewhere.
Oh no.
Wait.
LUDE!
Gravity?
Oh gosh, I think I remember it.
Let me write it down.
Why are you asking for such a soft song?
You have a soft spot.
Behind all that LUDE-ness.
There's somewhere soft.
In your heart.
Specifically.
Radiac!
Thank you for the 30 gifts!
Thank you, thank you.
Hey guys!
Thank you for the...
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Where did I put the karaoke?
One second.
Is it under this folder?
Maybe.
Ah yes!
The lyrics though.
Nico Nico Kumi Kyoku for finale!
Maybe not today.
I'm starting to get a little tired actually.
Actually mostly hungry which makes me tired.
Okay.
I'm going to go back to English songs after this one.
So don't worry if you were like...
She missed an English song.
Because I have a few English songs.
That I missed too.
Are those real?
Wait!
No!
No way!
No, no, no!
I lost it.
I have it.
Are these real?
Check your e-mail?
What do you mean check my e-mail?
Oh my God!
Stop!
Hold on!
I need to get the...
Cancel, cancel, cancel.
Wait, wait, wait.
Are those real?
Oh my God.
Wait, don't look at the screen.
Oh my gosh.
3 hours.
Play card!
Play, play, play card.
Oh no!
This is really slow.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh.
If these...Oh my God.
Is this?
Wait.
I don't know.
C?
Wait, I don't think this is correct.
Wait.
1...
No!
That one!
The first one didn't work.
Oh my God.
Back, back, back.
Oh my gosh.
I gotta be faster than anybody else.
Oh I don't know.
Oh gosh.
You guys shouldn't have posted in the chat.
I can't even follow.
Oh my gosh.
I don't want you to waste your money.
OK, let's see if this works.
But it's too much money!
It's 1,500 yen!
Oh my gosh.
Binary goes to...
You guys didn't...You guys didn't redeem it.
Oh my God!
Garlamo, you too!
Wait, can I...You guys, I'm gonna redeem it both.
I'm gonna redeem it.
Hold on.
I don't want you to waste your money.
Wait, how do I redeem another card?
Hold on.
Oh wait, I can do this.
I can go for the 30.
3,000.
And then just put in the card.
Oh my gosh.
You guys are crazy.
I told you not to put it in the card!
Oh my gosh.
T-L-Y.
I'm doing it, Garlamo!
You guys, seriously.
Ah, OK.
Oh
my gosh.
Thank you guys.
You guys, you chat were so good.
Oh my gosh.
You guys didn't redeem it.
How?
Why?
You guys are so good.
Oh my gosh.
You guys are so nice.
I can't believe you guys didn't redeem it before me.
I can't believe you guys were so...
We're so... We're so respectful.
That never happens.
Oh my god.
There could have been anybody who like just...
Who just came into chat and was like...
Oh, I'm going to take that now.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys.
That's insane.
There's so many people here and a single person took it.
How is that possible?
Oh my gosh.
I do have the best community.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
You guys are actually the best.
I hope you didn't hear me just gulp right now.
You were so slow too.
I know!
I know.
That's insane.
Thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
I can say I love EXE now.
But I feel so bad too because...
Because...
I can only redeem for 3 hours but I probably will only go for like another 30 minutes.
I'm not going to go for so long.
I can use it next time.
Is it okay if I use it next time?
You guys sent too much.
Save it for later then?
It's okay.
Georgie!
Hi!
Georgie is here.
Georgie who is so one hell made my game.
John!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
Tell the brand.
Welcome to my membership.
Thank you!
Did you guys beat the game?
I saw some people saying it was hard.
I'm just a lurker here but I salute to you Wisps.
You're a Wisp too!
What are you talking about?
Greg!
You've been here for 2 months!
You're a Wisp too!
What are you talking about?
Just a lurker?
That's... You're still here watching.
That's more than enough.
Honestly.
Sorry, I got really...
Really emotional about that.
First time coming into your stream.
You have really sweet voice.
Keep on singing.
Thank you DD!
Thank you!
We do be lurking.
Okay, I'm gonna save it for next time then.
Dog's drinks.
Thank you for the 20!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Everyone, welcome!
20XX welcome!
Lurker, I'm in love.
Shadow cross!
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Oh my gosh, where is all this coming from?
Lottie!
Thank you for the raid!
Oh my gosh, right now I'm a little...
Oh gosh, you guys came in...
You guys came in at a silly time.
Thank you for all the gifted.
Thank you.
You guys came in at a silly time.
Just an occasional lurker.
Thank you, froggy.
Frozen froggy.
Thanks for all the gifted!
Thank you!
This is the most emotional Nintendo code redeem I've ever seen.
I think it will be...
The most ever, right?
And Ashes, I'll check my email.
Unless you wanna use that.
It's totally on you.
Actually, you just said check my email.
I'm assuming.
I hope it's not.
If it is... Hold on, I'm checking my email.
I'm checking my email.
If it is...
You should use it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, Seymour!
I got your email.
Thank you.
Okay, I see it.
Thank you!
Thank you, Seymour.
Thank you, Carla1.
Thank you guys so much.
Okay, I was singing Odoriko.
Odoriko, Odoriko, Odoriko.
Odoriko, Odoriko.
I will sing it now for real.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I have to add suddenly Seymour to my list.
Garlamald, is there a song you want me to sing?
Is there a song you want me to sing?
Someone asked me to sing this earlier, but it's so embarrassing...
when there are people named the person in the song you're singing about in your chat.
This is live Muddy Laundry.
What?
No, you're not!
No, it's not!
How is it Muddy Laundry?
No!
FBI, turn away!
Close your eyes.
Are they closed?
Okay, I sing Odoriko.
Yeah, this is legitimate business.
I'm just waiting on my numbers.
To get approved.
For it to be a real, real business.
Hey, let's pick it up properly Before I break it and forget it Hey, if my future with that girl who started to spin If I could do it again somewhere else
Hey, if my future with that girl who started to spin
If I could do it again somewhere else Hey, if my future with that girl who started to spin Hey, if my future with that girl who started to spin If I could do it again somewhere else Hey, if my future with that girl who started to spin If I could do it again somewhere else
Dudududu...
If my future with that girl who started to spin If I could do it again somewhere else If I could do it again somewhere else Hey, if my future with that girl who started to spin If I could do it again somewhere else Hey, in what era will we live in love as always?
What will remain of us is the song of unchanging love Hey, in what era will we live in love as always?
What will remain of us is the song of unchanging love
Dudududu...
Odoriko!
Thank you!
Thank you for the pick Minchi!
Yoshi is amazing and you can't tell me otherwise
I'm assuming... I'm not gonna assume that I'm your Yoshi, but I will say that your Yoshi is probably really cool Thank you for the 50!
Thank you!
Oh, wait, hold on.
Oh, there we go So many gifts!
Holy cow!
I just saw how many gifts there have been today
You guys...
Okie-dokie.
I'm gonna go back to some English songs.
This one was a while ago
Did Garlemald say a song?
Did you say a song?
You?
Hello?
Okie-dokie See ya!
Thanks for the gifted!
Ah... Ah... Ah...
He said to sing what you like?
Thank you!
Can you say thanks for the 5 gifted?
Ok I think I have to turn this one up, like 2 key
There is freedom within, there is freedom without Try to catch the deluge in a paper cup There's a battle ahead, many battles are lost But you'll never see the end of the road while you're traveling with me Hey now, hey now, don't dream it's over Hey now,
hey now, when the world comes in They come, they come, to build a wall between us We know they won't win Now I'm towing my car, there's a hole in the roof My possessions are causing me suspicion but there's no proof In the paper today, tales of war and always But you turn right over to the TV page Hey now,
hey now, don't dream it's over Hey now, hey now, when the world comes in They come, they come, to build a wall between us We know they won't win Now
I'm walking ahead, to the beat of a drum And I'm counting the steps to the door of your heart Only shadows ahead, barely clearing the roof Get to know the feeling of liberation and release Hey now, hey now, don't dream it's over Hey now, hey now, when the world comes in They come,
they come, to build a wall between us We know they can't win
Win Yay, that was don't dream it's over
Ok, ok, ok
This was requested a while ago, we'll try to remember it Part of me doesn't remember quite much of it, Lewood, I'm sorry I'm sorry
Something always brings me back to you It never takes too long Time warp No matter what I say or do You still feel you here till the moment I'm gone You hold me without touch.
You keep me without chains.
I never wanted anything so much than to drown in your love and not feel your rain.
Set me free, leave me be.
I don't wanna fall another moment into your gravity.
Here I am, and I stand so tall, just the way that I'm supposed to be.
But you're onto me, and all over me.
Oh, you love me, cause I'm fragile.
When I thought that I was strong.
But you touch me for a little while, and all my fragile strength is gone.
Set me free, leave me be.
I don't wanna fall another moment into your gravity.
Here I am, and I stand so tall, just the way that I'm supposed to be.
But you're onto me, and all over me.
Wait, I don't remember this part.
Make you search for everything I've lost.
Sorry, I need the vocals here.
You're on the ground, but you're neither friend nor foe.
I can't seem to let you go.
The one thing that I still know is that you're keeping me down.
You're keeping me down.
Sorry, I always forget that part.
You're onto me, and all over
me.
Something always brings me back to you.
It never takes too long.
Sorry, I've gotta relearn this song.
It's been a long time since I've heard it.
I know I sang it before, but...
Gravity...
Writing my thesis today?
Good luck!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
First time catching a stream?
Wow.
I can say I really regret never catching one sooner.
Your voice is incredible.
Thank you!
It's all an illusion.
I cosplay as a good singer.
I'm not a good singer.
I pretend I wish I were a good singer.
I wish, I wish.
I wish, but thank you.
I appreciate it.
What's the difference between the musical and the film?
I don't know.
We'll see.
I gotta put on my accent.
I gotta put on my accent for this.
Because I gotta really channel Audrey.
I gotta really channel Audrey with this.
I'm just a downtown girl.
Mascara?
Oh, this is Seymour.
Thank you, Seymour.
Now they're okay?
Really, Seymour?
He's standing beside you.
Beside me?
Little old me?
You don't need no makeup.
Good, because I'm barefaced today.
Don't have to pretend.
Suddenly, Seymour...
is here to provide you...
sweet understanding.
Suddenly, Seymour...
is here to provide me.
He don't give me orders.
He don't condescend.
Suddenly, Seymour...
is here to provide me...
sweet understanding.
Seymour's my friend.
Tell me the bad times are clean washed away.
Please understand that it's still strange and frightening.
For losers like I've been, it's so hard to say.
Suddenly, Seymour...
he purified me.
showed me I can...
learn how to be a man.
The girl that's inside me.
What sweet understanding.
Your man.
Sorry, I couldn't hold out that note.
I'm getting hungry, that's why.
Oh my gosh.
I watched this movie for the first time ever...
on Halloween, many, many years ago.
So, let's see if I remember it.
I think I actually listened to...
Didn't Herb sing this recently?
Seymour.
Let's hear it.
Let's see.
Oh gosh.
Oh, it's like not a normal...
Blue singer, male, pink... wait, female singer, pink.
Oh gosh.
It's astounding.
Time is fleeting.
Madness...
takes its toll.
But listen closely.
Not for very much longer.
I've got to...
keep control.
I remember...
doing the time warp.
Drinking those...
moments when...
the blackness would hit me...
and the void would be calling.
Let's do the time warp again.
It's just a jump to the left.
And then a step to the right.
And you bring your knees in time.
But it's the pelvic
pain.
Let's do the time warp again.
It's so dreamy.
Oh fantasy, free me.
So you can't see me.
No, not at all.
In another dimension.
With voyeuristic intention.
Well secluded.
I see all.
With a bit of a mind flip.
And nothing's a time flip.
And nothing can ever be the same.
You're spaced out of sensation.
Like you're under sedation.
Let's do the time warp again.
Well I was walking down the street.
Just I happened to think.
And a snake of a guy gave me an evil wink.
Well he shook me up.
He took me by surprise.
He had a pickup truck.
I felt a change.
Time nap.
With your hands on your hips.
You bring your knees in tight.
That really drives you insane.
Let's do the time warp.
I'm surprised at how much I remembered of that song.
Oh my gosh.
Time warp.
I guess it's like one of those kind of iconic songs.
It's hard to forget, right?
You hear it once and you're like this is such an iconic song.
I have three more songs.
Well, maybe I should save this one for last.
Okay.
Actually, some people were requesting Snake Eater.
But I don't know if I want to sing it today since I sang it yesterday.
I did another Metal Gear song earlier.
I mean I always want to sing Metal Gear, but I don't know.
Herb of Vengeance, that's happening.
Maybe now.
Hold on, I want to...
I want to practice again.
If the world was ending, I want to be next to you.
Save it for MGS Karaoke whenever that happens.
MGS Karaoke.
Okay, I'll save it.
If the world was ending...
It was my B-Day a couple days ago.
I sadly missed your stream.
Bon Burgo, happy birthday.
Happy belated birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Bon Burgo.
I have always so many people requesting Skyfall, but like...
Or Adele.
I don't think I'm really good at Adele songs.
I don't think.
I don't think my voice is really suited for it.
Is all.
That's why I never sing them.
Rent Glory?
Something Glory.
Glory.
Oh gosh.
Thank you for the pick.
I don't know, I don't think I can sing Glory.
I don't remember it so well.
Something Glory.
Glory.
Uh...
You did remind me of a song that I...
Not the Glory though, but I saw someone remind me of a song that I...
Think I want to sing.
It's a Japanese song.
Let me see if there's a karaoke of it on YouTube.
Oh my gosh, there is.
I guess I want to sing...
This one's for me, guys.
This one's for me.
This one's for me, this one's for me.
I really like this song.
I love this song.
I heard it the other day on my mp3 player and I was like...
This song is so good.
Show us your Walkman, you hag!
It's in my car!
The pochi version is so good in this song.
I
have an older car, so I have to plug up my mp3 player to it, okay?
It's you, isn't it?
It's a little low for me, but...
This song is so good.
Asian Kung Fu generation.
Best thing that came from a race.
You said it, not me.
Okay, I have two songs left.
For real now.
Oh, let me do...
Let me do the one with Erb first.
Hold on.
Oh, let me set her up.
You might hear her for a second.
Oh no, you don't?
Okay, cool.
Let me set her up.
No, no, no.
Not that.
This.
I have to make sure I can...
Hear her.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, hold on.
Wait, wait, wait.
Hi, Erb.
I wonder if I should just play the audio.
No, I want to see her face.
Okay, and now I need to be able to hear her.
There we go.
Okay.
Hello, queen.
Hello.
This is so...
This is why I was just like...
It's kind of awkward for me.
So this is why I'm like...
This is the only time I'll do it, okay?
This is the last time I'll do it.
Okay.
I don't want to mess it up.
If I mess it up, I get a third time, okay?
If I mess it up, I'll get a third time.
Okay, I just want to listen to her sing.
Oh, here, I should make myself smaller.
Here, I'll just stand all the way in the back.
Okay.
Hi, everyone.
I'm looking at you.
Okay, cool.
Alright.
Oh, I need... Actually, sorry.
I just realized I need our lyrics split instead of just regular lyrics.
Not regular lyrics.
Lyrics split.
Okay, here we go.
Ooh
I, I just woke up from a dream Where you and I had to say goodbye And I don't know what it all means But since I survived, I realized Wherever you go, that's where I'll follow Nobody's promised tomorrow So I'ma love you every night like it's the last night Like it's the last night If the world was ending I'd want to be next to you If the party was over And our time on Earth was through Ooh,
I'd want to hold you just for a while.
And die with a smile.
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
Ooh.
Lost, lost in the words that we scream.
I don't even want to do this anymore.
Cause you already know what you mean to me.
And our love's the only war worth fighting for.
Wherever you go, that's where I'll follow.
Nobody's promised tomorrow.
So I'ma love you every night like it's the last night.
Like it's the last night.
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
Ooh.
If the party was over and our time on earth was through.
I'd want to hold you just for a while.
And die with a smile.
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
Right next to you.
Next to you.
Mint,
mint, mint, mint, mint, mint.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Hearts in chat, hearts in chat, hearts in chat.
Yeah!
Let's go!
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
Ooh.
If the party was over and our time on earth was through.
I'd want to hold you just for a while.
And die with a smile.
If the world was ending, I'd want to be next to you.
Ooh.
I'd want to be next to you.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for having me on your special day.
Thank you so much.
It means the world to me to sing with you.
I want to be next to you.
I want to be next to Maid Mint.
Thank you so much.
Have a great rest of your stream.
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you!
Buh-bye!
Yay!
Revenge happened!
I think that was better, baby.
Was it better?
Was it okay?
Oh my gosh.
She is just insane.
I hope she sings that song every karaoke.
But she needs to cover both voices.
I want to hear her do Lady Gaga's part too.
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
I'd die.
Thank you forever.
Okay, I have one last song.
It's another real...
What's the word?
Culture... No, not culture shock.
Whiplash!
Victor Song!
Thank you for the Aqua Super!
Thanks for two days of great singing.
I was having so much fun watching yesterday.
I forgot to pay for the parking at the gym.
Rather than pay for the parking company, here's the ticket.
Oh no!
The ticket!
No!
Oh my gosh.
Don't go.
Also, you standing on stage is incredibly cute.
I thought maybe I would have it...
I thought I would have it maybe closer today so you could see me more.
Okidoki.
I'm going to hold on to the mic for this one.
I'm going to hold on to the mic and I'm going to bring you guys in too.
Okidoki.
Okidoki!
Last song.
Turn it down.
Oh my god.
I don't want to wake up.
Everything is fucked.
Everybody sucks.
You don't really know why, but you want to justify ripping someone's head off.
No human contact.
And if you interact, your life is on contract.
Your best bet is to stay away, motherfucker!
It's just one of those days.
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit.
I think you better quit.
Let's slip straight.
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit.
I don't know why you guys always want me to sing this song so much.
Talking that shit.
It's just one of those days, feeling like a freight train.
First one to complain, leaves with a blood stain.
Damn right I'm a maniac.
You better watch your back, cause I'm fucking up the program.
If you're so stuck up, you just lucked up.
Next in line,
fuckers!
It's just one of those days.
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit.
I think you better quit.
Let's slip straight.
Or you'll be leaving with a fat lip.
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit.
I think you better quit.
Talking that shit.
So come and get it.
I feel like shit.
Not really.
My suggestion is to keep your distance.
Cause right now I'm dangerous.
We've all felt like shit.
And been treated like shit.
All those motherfuckers that wanna step up.
I hope you know I pack a chainsaw.
I rip your ass raw.
And if my day keeps going this way.
I just might break something tonight.
I pack a chainsaw.
I skin your ass raw.
And if my day keeps going this way.
I just might break something tonight.
I pack a chainsaw.
I skin your ass raw.
And if my day keeps going this way.
I just might break your fucking face tonight.
GIVE ME SOMETHING TO BREAK!
All
about the he says, she says bullshit I think you better quit, let shit slip Or you'll be leaving with a fat lip It's all
talk and not shit, huh?
So come and get it Yeah!
Thank you guys!
Thanks for coming to my karaoke!
I was blushing this whole time Cause I'm all hot and sweaty, you know I'm getting up here, breaking it down on my stage Yeah, yeah, yeah, thanks for the five kitties!
Thank you guys, thank you guys, thank you, thank you, thank you!
And...
Yeah, I'll see you guys!
This made me even more excited to see you at Phantom Thieves Revenge Live in Atlanta on December 14th Yes guys!
December 14th!
Live in Atlanta in 3D Looking like this 3D, not old Minto 3D New, new, new, new 3D So, you can come see Doki and I And some other special guests And watch us sing and dance and wiggle on stage!
So be sure to get your tickets, it's not the same day as the Hololive concert It's the day before, so you can just have a whole weekend of concert It would be so much fun!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
3.0 3D, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
That's what I said!
Actually, I was practicing the dance, one of the dances that Doki and I are gonna do I think it's actually one of the only dances Well, it's like the most choreographed dance, I would say I was practicing it just earlier today!
So, yeah, unskippable ad Why would you want to skip this ad, huh?
Meryl, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Shawn, thanks for the 5 gifted!
3D.0 Yeah, so...
And actually, next week, we'll be...
She and I will be...
Going...
We'll be meeting up actually for practice
So...
Yeah, maybe Maybe be on the lookout for other collab while we're together Maybe, I don't know
Yeah!
Thank you guys!
Thanks for coming to my karaoke!
Thanks for coming to listen to me sing!
Really appreciate it!
Eastern Telecom, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye bye!
Otsumito!